quanta bellezza ragazzi che bella serata
che bella giornata quante cose belle
abbiamo sentito e questo ci porta a
ragionare sulla bellezza per capire se
riusciamo ad avere la farà diventare
sistema e questo è quello che io ed
altri altri nostri compagni di viaggio
abbiamo cercato di fare di porta
attraverso la riflessione che ci ha
portato a questo di porto se ci vado si
al cuore
beh questa bellezza noi italiani bravi
tutto ma insomma hanno italiani il paese
non piace è una cosa terribile guardate
la reputation institute ci dice che
giusto giusto al 50 per cento degli
italiani piace questo paese
raramente ho sentito la roba del genere
ma peggio ancora o meglio ancora grazie
a dio
piace al 65,8 per cento degli altri
quindi un gap fantastico di 15 punti tra
quanto noi amiamo il nostro paese quanto
piace agli altri allora da un lato lo
dice ma siete proprio infermi dall'altro
magari delle opportunità questo mi
sembra essere un segnale interessante
anche perché l'autostima sembra che
serva al mondo se guardiamo alle tigri
del pil come vengono definite anno
un'autostima straordinaria mentre noi
abbiamo meno 15 loro hanno più 30 più 27
più 17 in russia addirittura più 35 ma
solo un po di fanfaroni per cui noi li
ho messi dentro però guardate che roba
questa è gente che compete nel mondo ai
credi in quello che fa quindi quello che
un po mi vien da dire è che sia un
grande paese che non sa più di esserlo
abbiamo perso speranza perso energia
perso fiducia in noi e allora bisogna
vederne fuori in qualche modo e noi
abbiamo pensato che venirne fuori vuol
dire fare un grande progetto identitario
vuol dire ridare un senso a quello che
siamo per ridare fiducia ai cittadini
per ricostruire ridare centralità al
ruolo delle imprese questa mattina e la
zambon ci ha raccontato di un impresa
eccellente mauro parlava di imprese
generative noi abbiamo in questo paese
straordinario
le straordinarie imprese che però non
sono mai state chiamate a prendersi
responsabilità sul paese spesso non
hanno voluto farlo neanche loro
forse è venuto il momento che invece
l'impresa abbia un opportunità per
giocare al suo ruolo in termini di paese
dobbiamo aumentare la reputazione lo
sviluppo economico del paese e
coinvolgere istituzioni e governi quando
si ha un sogno il sogno è sempre pieno
di ambizioni un sogno senza ambizioni
che sogno è quindi io ce l'ho messa
tutta i miei compagni di viaggio
sembrano a seguirmi su questa follia
io non sono abbastanza vecchio per avere
sentito de gasperi ma tutto quello che
ho sentito dopo è la dimostrazione dove
la classe dirigente senza nessuna
visione questo paese ragiona a 3
forse sei mesi la cina ragiona a 150
anni ora io non pretendo che da tre mesi
si passi a 150 anni ma io mi son detto
che per cambiare questo paese almeno 20
ci vogliono io no 64 tengo vende alla
mia salute e io penso che per i prossimi
20 anni
starò su questo progetto per fare cosa
perché non è possibile che il mio paese
non abbiano un ruolo nel mondo
non siamo mica ratello sull'industria
non so se ne avete sentito parlare è
allora quando penso ai cittadini di
questi paesi che gli piaccia o no hanno
tutti un'idea molto chiara di dove sta
andando il paese in termini di politica
economica politica industriale
educazione ruolo diplomatico pensate che
cos'era la corea 40 anni fa e che cos'è
diventata oggi allora mi dico ma insomma
un paese che non sa immaginare il
proprio futuro non ha l'energia per
costruirlo e come si definisce il futuro
con una parola chiave che oggi abbiamo
sentito tante volte e che io ho usato
per il mio mestiere aveva usato per
educare i miei figli per portare avanti
la mia azienda ed è la parola talento
chi scopre il proprio talento scopre un
tesoro
ogni mattina si alza e quello che fa e
riempire di gioia perché esprime dà vita
al suo talento
e allora applichiamolo al paese
qual è il talento di questo paese ma è
troppo facile 800 anni fa del costituto
senese si leggeva che chi governa da
vera massimamente a cuore la bellezza
della città per ragioni di diletta e
allegrezza ai forestieri per
accrescimento e trasferita della città e
dei cittadini intanto il lorenzetti
dipingeva al buon governo nella casa
comunale della città quando 800 anni fa
era già chiarissimo questo dovevamo fare
ma lo è che solo c'era il dettato cento
anni fa hanno continuato a dircelo
attraverso i secoli il buon gusto è
piuttosto che brahms piuttosto che renzo
chiamo ogni 3x4 ci dice che la bellezza
il nostro asse il più straordinario ma
noi non ce ne curiamo siamo come un
pesce che nuota nel mare più bello del
mondo ma visto che il suo compito notare
che maria bello brutto poco gli importa
e quindi non ce ne accorgiamo per gli
italiani e la bellezza deve trasformarsi
nella consapevolezza diffusa che è il
più grande patrimonio che noi abbiamo e
attraverso questo competere perché
abbiamo un primato straordinario
ciascuno di noi con le sue scelte i suoi
comportamenti può fare in modo che
l'italia diventi appunto la patria della
bellezza
due parole chiave la prima poco
frequentata in questo paese perenne
ragioni che non staremo a vedere ma
anche perché il concetto di patria è
fortemente legato al senso dello stato
ora senso dello stato ed è un bene che a
noi manca sui 40mila anni prima che ci
arrivi condivido un passo ma se piglio
patria e faccio una casi con bellezza vi
prendo a bolzano e vi molla siracusa
l'esperienza di bellezza che vi faccio
fare è unica al mondo
la polverizzazione di offerta di
bellezza e ineguagliabile
non esiste sulla terra un pezzo lungo
1.200 chilometri che abbia dentro più di
venti capitali ora cultura manifattura
architettura cucine tradizioni ognuna di
queste capitale a un dato momento nella
sua storia ha tratto su di sé il meglio
che si poteva offrire ad avere provata
attraversa renne brasca
oppure ma ma senza andare lontano
andiamo in francia la grande francia la
grande partito più cazzo vuol dire una
meravigliosa campagna ma dov'è quella
straordinaria competenza ma in grado di
offrire quindi voglio dire davvero è è
impressionante quello che sappiamo
offrire
aggiungo una cosa è oggi se ne è sentito
molto l'aggettivo bello e usato nella
lingua italiana come nessun'altra lingua
al mondo una bella riunione la bella
vacanza un bel film una bella persona
i bambini quando litigano ti dicono che
sei brutta cattivo che il contrario di
bello e buono per cui noi abbiamo della
bellezza un senso che va molto al di là
dell'estetica
era questo tengo molto perché sennò si
rischia che la bellezza sia frivola no
la bellezza è pesantissima
luigi zoja ha scritto un libro
bellissimo su bellezza e verità
scusatemi il su giustizia e bellezza
come sono e sappiamo dai nostri filosofi
greci che sono esattamente alla faccia
le due facce della stessa medaglia
allora questa bellezza è appunto per gli
italiani qualcosa che ha a che vedere
con quella qualità di vita che il mondo
intero ci invidia perché andiamo
cercando quell'armonia che il food il
paesaggio le relazioni i luoghi riescono
a darci mestieri e il suo radar ci vede
faccio rapidamente una carrellata ma
oggi se n'è parlato molto io ne ho altri
25 di queste slight fa impressione
vedere la difesa diversità la
biodiversità della bellezza naturale che
siamo in grado di offrire piuttosto che
questa che è venuta fuori anche oggi
nella relazione di ceylon lì mi pare che
si chiamino quando ci ha spiegato come
importante alla relazione gli italiani
hanno tanti difetti ma nessuno al mondo
ti dirà che sono antipatici
abbiamo una capacità unica al mondo di
relazionarci costruire relazioni
empatiche questo perché francia spagna
purché se magna perché la nostra vita
nelle piazze la centralità della
famiglia ci sono molte ragioni e quelle
ragioni diciamo sempre spinta l'ascolto
che è quello che se holly ci diceva io
quando compito in giro col per il mondo
per con i miei concorrenti più bravo
melo bravo più caro melo caro
ma io so che c'è una cosa che gli altri
novello io li sto ascoltare perché mi
interessa capire perché solo se mi
interessa capire se capisco che riesco a
darmi la cosa che vuole è nella maniera
migliore
ecco questa è una qualità che noi
abbiamo di nuovo come il pesce è un nota
nel mare non ce ne rendiamo più conto ma
sappiate che una delle cose più
straordinarie che attira la gente in
questo paese per il piacere di stare con
lui ogni tanto siamo proposti concetti
però non è che è sempre così
attenzione se te ne vai in piazza san
marco a prenderti un caffè un amaro e
c'è uno che strimpella in maniera
inascoltabile un violino e lo scontrino
che ti arriva con cento euro
allora non sei simpatico lo sei
accogliente sicuro un pò farabutto
attenzione perché questa grande qualità
che il mondo intero ci invidia
ogni tanto ne cela dimentichiamo e non
dovremmo scusate c'è tutta la questione
del volontariato la storia di
sant'egidio una tipico esempio della
capacità straordinaria di questo paese
tutta quella di lampedusa stamattina che
mi ha fatto venire le lacrime agli occhi
questa cappa ma io credo che non voglio
togliere lui lampedusani anzi ma credo
che moltissimi di noi a lampedusa in
quella condizione avrebbero fatto la
stessa cosa perché viene dal nostro modo
di essere dall'empatia e quindi dall
ascolto dell'altro
la bellezza non è mica solo tarallucci e
vino e noi siamo dei numeri uno della
farmaceutica per citare zambon ma lo
siamo nella meccanica nella
meccanotecnica nell'automazione nei
motori
siamo numeri uno al mondo e siamo il
secondo paese manifatturiero d'europa e
abbiamo un saper fare che è
assolutamente unico quindi
ricordiamocelo
poi c'è tutto il retaggio della bottega
rinascimentale il made in italy su che
cosa si basa su quella straordinaria
capacità di fare il bello fatto in
termini artigianali e di grande qualità
attenzione perché questa è una filiera
che purtroppo ai piedi d'argilla
pensate che in giappone li chiamano i
tesori evidenti in francia li chiamo li
metto va da herat a noi in italia lo
chiamiamo l'operaio specializzato allora
l'opera specializzato e
il il tesoro vivente voi vi rendete
conto che c'è uno spazio infinito di
valutazione valorizzazione sociale
economica e di ruolo di uomini
fondamentali per questo comparto la
fondazione cologna ha fatto una ricerca
sulla prodotte sulla sulla qualità della
produzione nella filiera del made in
italy ha preso cinque aziende tra gli 80
ei 150 milioni di fatturato e sono
andati a guardare chi produce chi
produce cose come boe in queste aziende
ci sono date a cinque persone che fanno
la differenza tra un prodotto cinese un
prodotto fatto da noi questo l'operaio
specializzato che ineluttabilmente
diventa operaio pensionato perché non lo
sostituisce nessuno perché nessuno sa
fare quel mestiere allora se ne parlava
stamattina contava in garden e così via
abbiamo una grandissimo bisogno di
ridare forza a questi settori
riportando i giovani a guardare a questo
come una possibilità di sviluppo e di
passione di trovare il proprio talento
certo bisogna pagarli meglio certo
bisogna dargli modo di espletare questo
e usare i saperi dei nostri poveri
operai specializzati che diventino
invece dei maestri che insegnano nei
laboratori delle aziende la moda lo sta
un po facendo questo ma di tanti altri
comparti non si fa che insegni in questo
grande saper fare a noi abbiamo pare il
60 50 70 per cento i beni culturali al
mondo che è una iattura spaventosa
perché noi abbiamo la lira per
governarle quindi bisognerà trovare
soluzioni e anche abbiamo punte di
cultura che ci rappresentano nel mondo e
che sono uniche alitalia e buffo pensare
che abbiamo vinto l'oscar con la vita è
bella e l'abbiamo vinto con la grande
bellezza
qualcosa ci deve essere anche il mondo
ci riconosce in questo bene è l'anno
dell'expo ma non è per questo che siamo
bravi in questo comparto
otto anni bui il capo di danone diceva
poi scoperto quello diceva che cioè live
forse per altre ragioni
che nel mondo avanzeranno due grandi
culture alimentari che sono quella
cinese e quella italiana
perché la biodiversità la ricettazione
la nelle materie prime questi due paesi
sono in grado di mettere in campo
scenderanno in realtà dettaglio le
cucine di altri paesi
beh ragazzi detto dal francese non è
mica male allora
insomma di che bellezza parliamo
parliamo di via la bellezza che la
strategia del vero citando plotino
platone il bello il buono il giusto e il
ben fatto e questa pluralità di bellezza
che ci permette di essere competitivi
nel mondo ed è questa la maestria nel
saperli utilizzare tutti che ci farà
vincere le competizioni del futuro
allora che missione sia data la nostra
fondazione fare del nostro potenziale di
bellezza una risorsa strategica per il
paese trasformandolo in una leva di
politica economica e sociale non va
pagato nessuno io sognare bosso
se vi dico italia partner dalla bellezza
esprimo quella che noi tecnici che
amiamo l'identità competitiva del paese
si basa fondamentalmente su quattro assi
che sono la ricchezza della molteplicità
che di cui abbiamo parlato la creatività
del nostro ingegno perché il nostro
ingegno è la nostra creatività si usata
ingegnosa noi mettiamo le mani in quello
che facciamo e pensiamo quell'arte di
saper vivere che non vi sto a raccontare
perché ormai ce l'ha raccontata a tutti
ma poi c'è questo casino qua cioè noi
qui se lo mettiamo a posto la litica dei
nostri comportamenti tutto il resto non
stare in piedi allora essendoci dati 20
anni
io dico che in 20 anni un po ci si può
però si può provare di lavorarci credo
che sia una proposta significante unica
memorabile che porti valore al paese gli
faccio un paio di esempi di american
dream e ancora oggi è l'identità
competitiva degli stati uniti
e se noi vogliamo parlare di innovazione
voltiamo la testa ad occidente laddove
c'è una cultura e un popolo un paese che
nel dna ha il senso del superamento
della frontiera del challenge continuo
della sfida a superare le difficoltà chi
fallisce in america è uno che ci ha
provato a gli si dà credito per la
seconda volta alla quinta lo si manda a
casa
l'idea che ci sta che uno ci provi vale
molto se chiudo la portiera di una bmw
di una audi risuona la deutsche scali
tet e quando andiamo a comprare la
lavatrice se c'è una candia c'è una
borsa beh se abbiamo 20 per cento di
euro in più c'è comprarla bosch perché i
pezzi più solidi per che durerà di più
perché l'assistenza verrà fuori prima
poi mette in italia la boxe ma
costruisce la carne ma questo non
importa
sta di fatto che il valore germania e
quello
chiudo con uno scudetto rosso con sulla
croce bianca to dovunque lo pone il
senso di precisione esattezza cura con
cui quella cosa è fatta che fate
rifornimenti per cento in più quindi
nella nell'immaginario collettivo
attraverso le esperienze non attraverso
la pubblicità si concretizzano delle
letture delle qualità che i paesi sono
in grado di esprimere di eddy e di
raccontare perché noi lo testimoniamo
perché luogo lo testimoniano a noi con i
loro comportamenti nei loro prodotti
allora il credo che nessun paese al
mondo possa prendere la bellezza come
suo elemento di racconto tanto quanto lo
può fare l'italia
quindi ci dobbiamo lavorare non è tutto
regalato ma la verità è che noi ci siamo
già lì perché visto che le cose nascono
dalla verità la bellezza degli italiani
e la producono e la posseggono e la
producono da che mondo è mondo quindi
non stiamo dicendo niente di nuovo e
abbiamo parlato in bellezza tutto il
giorno e ce ne rendiamo conto
il problema è che non siamo capaci di
raccontarla la raccontiamo poco e male
pensate l'anno scorso a londra al
british museum una casa pompeiana
raccontata è stata la mostra più
visitata negli ultimi 15 anni in
inghilterra in quattro mesi ha staccato
11 milioni di biglietti che io immagino
voglia dire 100 milioni di indotto
magliette cazzatine ristoranti alberghi
viaggi da dove siamo noi facciamo un
arco di 35 km ci sono almeno 25 cose che
noi potremmo mettere a valore
leggevo questa mattina sul giornale che
noi abbiamo i nostri dunque
l'inghilterra 15 siti sono 17 siti
dell'unesco
noi ne abbiamo 17 solo al sud abbiamo 50
l'inghilterra fa otto volte quello che
facciamo noi avendo un terzo alla
quantità dei siti i ragazzi dobbiamo
svegliarci perché non si sa mai evidente
questo io che lavoro con la media
impresa italiana l'imprenditore italiano
e anche lui appassionatissimo di
prodotto quando c'è da spendere soldi
per un prodotto è sempre pronto a lungo
il capannone compro nuovo bilico c'è una
norma che ne produzione a mettere in
campo sull'intangibilità chiamo così
così parliamo pochissimo l'inglese
abbiamo dei siti che fanno schifo non
facciamo ecommerce a va poi non
brevettiamo cioè la germania breve te a
33 mila brevetti all'anno
l'italia 4500 attenzione 1500 un'azienda
sola ne avanzano 3000 allora quando
quelli vanno a fare le classifiche per
vedere dove sta l'innovatività dei paesi
io credo che noi stiamo a cavallo tra il
gabon e la tanzania però non è vero voi
chi chi di voi conosce un imprenditore
italiano tutti i giorni si fa un
accrocchio si inventa una roba nuova
migliore alla sua macchina migliore la
sua offerta e che non c'ha voglia poi
non ci crede devo andare a spendere
soldi poi devo aspettare che la
burocrazia mi dia la cosa poi tanto già
venduti a penso al prossimo ma questo è
al di là della mia via se volete su
questo punto è anche il fatto che non
valorizza tanto quello che fa non si
rende conto che noi siamo capaci di fare
cose straordinarie che val la pena
proteggere perché questo vuol dire
ricchezza
allora che cosa ci siamo detti
costruiamo una una fondazione in cui
portiamo dentro tutti quelli che stanno
già facendo qualcosa per questo paese ce
n'è tanti perché abbiamo visto che
questo è un paese che è pronto a dare a
generativo in questo senso col concetto
quindi di portare fondazioni che già
fanno questo al nostro tavolo per
aggregarli per fare in modo che si conta
milo perché questi non si provano il
campanile ero sempre io faccio la mia
fondazione faccio i cazzi me faccio tu
non devi sapere nulla io lavoro sulla
mia fondazione
eravamo sul mio tema invece gran tempo
che facciamo sistema su questa cosa
perché ci riguarda tutti
quindi la contaminazione è un
grandissimo valore su chi sta facendo il
bene del paese e quindi è interessato al
bene del paese
questo può accelerare i processi e può
permetterci
diffondere poi una visione del paese
differente da quella che abbiamo
quelli che vedete qua sotto sono una
serie di partner sono dei sostenitori
dei promotori dei i partner culturali
sono dei partner operativi sono tanti
cresceranno nel tempo mi auguro andremo
a cercare poi abbiamo una lista di 400
aziende che abbiamo selezionate tra
questo vorremmo scegliere alle 200
aziende che meglio rappresentano
l'eccellenza del nostro paese
se dobbiamo scegliere noi perché devono
essere coerenti con la promessa della
della fondazione e anche perché vogliamo
che diventi un po i paladini del
progetto naturalmente nel tempo poi
troveremo molte altre aziende che stanno
dentro per questo tipo di di offerta
l'obiettivo è quello di comunicare
l'identità competitiva del paese a
livello mondiale per la dobbiamo prima
di tutto educare i nostri a capire la
politica ora di gioco per il modo di
dire solo il più bello del mondo poi
quando vengo qui o le strade più brutte
più bucate più schifosi ponti che
crollano e compagnia bella
qui c'è un grande lavoro da fare sulla
comunità nazionale e fare della marca
italia una pietra angolare del progetto
questo perché perché il nostro paese non
ha i colori figlia non lo si riconosce
non ha un suo segno non ha un suo modo
di raccontarsi sono state fatte alcuni
tentativi devo dire con un risultato non
particolarmente felice e quindi ci siamo
detti ma proviamo un po a raccontare
queste mille italia fate di piazze e
centri storici di cultura e paesaggio di
food e accoglienza di artigianato di
qualità di industria insomma mancano i
pezzi ma va bene uguale
siamo un racconto poliedrico siamo un
caleidoscopio non è che io posso
raccontare attraverso un segno quello
che è il nostro paese
e così ci siamo inventati quanto segue
reperto
diego
a me piace tutto di
non so se lo sono
st 6 vorrei che fossi qui e quando
ancora piccolo
ei beni
grazie grazie grazie
questo dovrebbe essere il segno di
promozione del paese in giro per il
mondo ma questo è solo un segno c'è ben
altro da fare quindi la fondazione in
realtà si pone l'obiettivo di parlare
con quattro interlocutori quattro aree
ad interventi e ben dodici progetti che
abbiamo lanciato di cui 6 sono già
pronti lavoreremo sul misurare su
dedicare sull'educare lo sviluppare e il
promuovere per quanto riguarda la misura
che ci occuperemo di andare a leggere
l'impressione che gli stranieri hanno
del nostro paese nel viaggio in italia
molto importante ci siamo inventati
siamo inventati abbiamo definito quello
che noi possiamo essere l'economia della
bellezza e vogliamo che il pil sia trovi
dentro il pil
la sua fetta noi supponiamo e pensiamo
che sia intorno al 30 per cento
allora se io riesco a dimostrare questo
e definirne dentro tutti i comparti
riesco davvero a muovere il paese a
capire che quella un elemento
fondamentale del nostro del nostro
futuro
la scuola sarà fondamentale dobbiamo
aiutare i ragazzi a incontrare la
bellezza ma dovevo fare di più nelle
scuole medie voglio porterei che noi
riuscissimo a trovare il modo di portare
le ragazze a incontrare l'economia della
bellezza dei loro territori di modo che
possano scoprire i loro talenti perché
sono vogliono fare le veline i cantanti
i cantanti di xfactor roba del genere
invece noi abbiamo quella filiera di cui
parlavamo prima che è fantastica e
straordinaria ma bisogna che i ragazzi
siano esposti a queste a queste
meraviglie potremo fare comunicazione
per raccordare il paese usare i luoghi
che diventano testimonianza del fatto
che siamo la patria della bellezza usare
le grandi manifestazioni che ci
rappresentano fare come file audio york
che speriamo di riuscirci anche noi
usare tutti i momenti in cui cultura
sport o roba del genere family degas
fuori d'italia quindi racconta sul
posizionamento pure tutte le mattine
quando andiamo a lavorare a raccontiamo
quello dietro qual è il nostro
posizionamento due parole ancora su
quello che si vede ecuador everything in
its di camagüey tourer station
in chiaro because the nation
questi sono le banane ragazzi noi ci
abbiamo tutto il made in italy per
raccontare cosa siamo in giro per il
mondo giusto no
allora funziona così suppone che lo
mettiamo che se quello che ho presentato
al ministro martino ma ha detto lo
facciamo partire con l'expo e alla fine
del rispondo mettiamo su tutte le
bottiglie venga roma dieci persone
un'ora di conversazione con tutti questi
si alza il ministro dice fra dieci
giorni ci vediamo e facciamo partire il
progetto
l'avete mai più sentito il ministro
lascia perdere comunque sia l'idea è che
io sono a tokyo mi compro una bottiglia
di chianti
clicco sul mio casco e o il filmino
sull'italia
ti spiego che cos'è il gallo nero e che
cos'è il chianti classico per youtube
non lo sai ti dico dove puoi comprare
alla bottiglia che stai bevendo a un
chilometro dal ristorante in cui sei
posso anche batterci dentro un numero di
anticontraffazione che ti dice che
quella bottiglia deve essere a tokyo e
non a brasilia ultimo la nostra la
nostra i nostri corso nate nella nostra
ambasciata
possono mandarci un messaggio che ti
dicono guarda fra dieci giorni e ci
hanno mostrano tiziano a kyoto
meravigliosa vanno a vedere allora tutti
i nostri prodotti possono diventare dei
fantastici emissarie del nostro
messaggio con grande soddisfazione vi
dico che il mio amico ferrari sta
stampando le retro etichette delle sue
bottiglie e con intanto il marchietto e
quindi comincia a raccontare il nostro
posizionamento alla questione della
partita è più complessa ma te solo non
vi voglio tediare chiudiamo con
l'aspetto con l'aspetto turisti nella
valorizzazione del nostro territorio ci
siamo inventati i percorsi della
bellezza inventati in realtà tanta gente
fa questo ma vogliamo mettere del
sistema
cosa vuol dire questo vuol dire mappare
tutto il paese tutte le bellezze
economiche culturali agricole di
ricezione somma un patrimonio
straordinario che semmai dall'alto in
basso lo riuscirai mai a fare ma se
invece fai dal basso in alto riesce a
fare ci sono due piattaforme con le
quali stiamo lavorando una nei territori
è una delle città che ci verranno donate
perché noi ne possiamo a nostra volta
cedere ai territori che vogliono
utilizzarlo
faccio un rapido esempio siamo in
provincia di lyman ca trento
eccolo qui che arriva scegliamo la città
di trento scegliamo il tipo di cosa che
ci interessa cioè l'argomento
fondamentale sul quale vogliamo
costruire il nostro percorso ci
aggiungiamo un paio di altre cose per
esempio
shopping sightseeing e poi diciamo c'è
un giorno un giorno e mezzo per stare
bene
questo è il percorso che puoi farlo
queste sono le cose che puoi incontrare
poi le racconti al mondo
fai dell ecommerce di cui io ti ho dato
alla piattaforma e mandano in giro per
il mondo i nostri prodotti
bene io credo che il mondo abbia bisogno
di bellezza e che il mondo abbia bisogno
d'italia grazie